[Music]
so press preview time it's a first look
at Sunday's front pages and tonight
we'll have a look at the headlines with
the political commentator Benedict
Spence and the journalist and author
Rachel shabby great to see you both this
Saturday evening we'll speak in a moment
after we've had a look at those front
pages four years starting with the
Observer uh claims from a whistleblower
who says some children seeking asylum in
the UK have been threatened with
violence by staff at a home office Run
Hotel
the Sunday Telegraph is reporting more
than half a million patients a year will
be treated in so-called hospitals at
home to help relieve pressure on
emergency departments
while the Sunday Express says there's a
row erupting between the Prime Minister
and Senior civil servants over plans to
tackle the migrant crisis
and the Daily Star says Britain's going
to be hit by a new weather phenomenon
dumping Donuts
whatever next
let's have a look at that and a reminder
that by scanning the QR code you can see
on screen join the program you can check
out the front pages of tomorrow's papers
while you're watching us discussing them
and to discuss them I'm joined by
Benedict Spence and Rachel shabby so uh
Rachel why don't we start then with this
story uh on the front of the Sunday
Telegraph it's quite a headline isn't it
hospitals at home explain
well yeah it is quite the headline I
don't think it's quiet hospitals at home
it's a plan that uh the government has
unveiled and it wants to
um basically do triage for particularly
elderly people in the home so that's to
avoid
um people coming into a e it's not it's
not a terrible idea on its base that you
know according according to them the
reason for this and it has been trialed
I think in one um NHS trust the reason
is that a lot of people who come to a e
actually might not need to
um plus you can see why for a lot of
elderly people it might actually be
easier and more comfortable to be
assessed at home so the idea is that
they send out
um uh expert an assessment that would
that would be taking place within two
hours in the home and then they'd be
brought in to hospital if needs be so
it's not on its face a terrible idea you
can see that it would ease the burden on
a e although of course it doesn't get
around the issue that comes up when you
talk to anybody who works in the NHS
anyone who works as a doctor or
particularly on the front line ambulance
services and within a e that the massive
issue here is underfunding
um both in terms of capital investment
and in terms of the day-to-day running
of the NHS and that's been going on for
over a decade so it doesn't skirt that
issue but it's not on its base a
terrible idea either yeah Benedict um
would you agree I mean I think everyone
understands that we need some sort of uh
thinking outside the box when it comes
to solving issues in the NHS on the face
of it is this sensible
well I suppose you know that the thing
is I mean this is being packed back
according to the telegraph where a 14
billion pound package so yeah it's not
an insignificant amount of money
um the one fear I suppose I would have
over it is a bit like when people often
call 111 because they're told not to
ring 999 and not to go to an emergency
Ward and very often what people find is
the advice is to just go to a e you know
this will have to be very properly
thought out as to what it is that uh
specially trained Medics uh can deal
with and what they will end up having to
do
um at the home rather than just turning
up within two hours and saying to people
oh well this isn't actually within my
remit you might as well go to a e
because very often uh that is the advice
that is given to people but you know the
the fact remains we have shifting
demographics in this country the
population is getting older and the
birth rate is falling that means that
even if the NHS even if Mauritius sunac
manages to pull multiple rabbits out of
the hat and he manages to make it
incredibly efficient and he increases
the number number of doctors and nurses
that we are producing and he manages to
find All the Monies found this every
year the NHS will necessarily fall
behind because of the changing
demographics this plan looks to address
people you know predominantly who are
part of the elderly uh or who are
slightly more infirm than the average so
it will go some way towards addressing
part of the problem at its heart so
you're right it's thinking outside of
the box it's trying to make things a
little more manageable so there isn't
that sort of that big bed blocking
phenomenon uh in in a e departments
where people can't get discharged
because they're considered to be too
frail because they'll just end up coming
back so I think it will alleviate some
of the pressures but it is going to be a
long-term thing it's not going to solve
any of the immediate issues uh I think
that you're currently seeing affecting a
e departments um as well as ambulance
Crews and nurses and doctors around the
country at the moment so it's welcome in
the sense that it is Forward Thinking it
is proactive so I think that that should
be welcomed at the least yeah and
actually Rachel using using Tech is some
something we're seeing more and more
we're seeing GP surgeries now doing
appointments online and in many cases
not in every case but in many cases that
does work
yeah you're absolutely right it's not
for everyone and just to clarify
um you know up to a third of of beds in
hospitals any one time are occupied by
people who are able to be discharged
because of social care because there
aren't social care packages in place so
that's cuts to social care that have
caused that situation again it comes
back to cuts
um yeah those um virtual surgeries again
they're not for everyone but they can
take some pressure off I mean I think
Benedict is right that it has to be done
very carefully you know some things you
would assume could only take place in
hospital
um so you'd have to go there anyway just
to make sure scans x-rays tests
um you know there are things that can
only be done in hospitals so it would
have to be executed very carefully but
if it is the case that you know
sometimes people have had a full say and
and don't need to go to hospital well
then that's a good thing and if they're
you know elderly and don't necessarily
feel you know would prefer to be seen at
home then you know these are all things
that should be considered it doesn't get
away though from the overall thing of
underfunding which is what everybody who
works in the NHS keeps telling us you
know it because they keep telling Skye
yeah and you you make that very uh uh
that point very well let's move on then
from the NHS to uh the front of the
Observer and uh an exclusive by then
which is by them Richie sunac Benedict
was warned about the zahawi tax risk
yes I mean from my reading this story it
is that Mr sunac was given a informal
discussions uh when he became prime
minister that Mr zahari had made a
significant settlement uh before sunap
became prime minister and and that it
was not uh that it was not the sort of
thing that could just be swept under the
rug that it was the sort of thing that
could do uh they call it reputational
damage to the government were he to be
put in a particularly important position
uh clearly whatever information Mr sunat
was given did not persuade him uh the
the the the the Mr zahawi's position was
untenable because obviously he's become
part of chairman that's very significant
and you know perhaps this is because Mr
sunak looked at uh Mr zahawi's record uh
under Boris Johnson it must be said he
is uh Mr zawi was perhaps one of the few
people to emerge from the Boris Johnson
years if not with his reputation
enhanced at the very least with most of
it intact given his performance on the
vaccine roll out uh if nothing else so
perhaps he thought that this was you
know a gamble worth taking perhaps he
wasn't given the full picture if it was
just an informal discussion uh but um
unquestionably your questions have been
asked about Richardson X judgment uh
therefore in appointing Mr zahawi to
prominent position uh in government if
he was aware of the circumstances
surrounding him and this is I'm afraid
this this is a story that's just going
to continue to run and run
um it is not a good look even when a
Tory government is doing well in the
polls uh for accusations uh of of
um of of sleaze or of misbehavior
whatever it is whatever the allegations
are it is never great to be a government
minister in that position and as a prime
minister to have sort of kicked it into
the long grass and say oh well I will
hand it over to my ethics guy sir Laurie
Magnus and he can deal with it those
questions around his ability to control
his party I'm afraid we'll also continue
yeah still waiting for the findings of
of that inquiry of course although down
his street strongly denying Rachel that
Richie sunap was given an informal
warning
well sure
um they would wouldn't they um because
it goes against the whole impression
that um the Prime Minister has been
saying all week which is you know I
didn't know
um but it is but it is also
kind of confirming what we we sensed the
whole week which is that inevitably this
position of I didn't know and
everything's fine will become untenable
um that that um the Dems of how we will
have to go and the thing is about this
is that
you know I think Benedict is right that
it is just going to keep play dragging
out but the longer it drank style the
more damage it does to the conservative
so as we know aren't doing great in the
polls to begin with but it just brings
to the front and center this idea of the
disparity the one rule for them and
another rule for us the idea that you
know everybody does pay tax and does do
the right thing
um and it's not that's how he has done
anything illegal here of course but it
is you know a loophole that is available
to him and it looks bad and it makes
people resentful so the longer it's in
the news the longer that feeling of
resentment is is activated and provoke
okay um let's stay with the front of the
Observer because they've got another
exclusive here actually
um a whistleblower has spoken to the
paper
um about uh children facing uh all sorts
of um uh awful bullying at one of of
these Asylum hotels Benedict
yes and of course this comes hot on the
heels of the story about hundreds or a
dozens certainly but potentially
hundreds of children and young people
going missing whilst in temporary
accommodation it also comes from the
back of other stories about the home
office not delivering information to
Asylum Seekers because they're not
allowed to whilst they're stuck in
temporary accommodation yeah it's it's
all a bit of a mess really and I don't
think that comes as a shock to anybody
this is just the latest sort of
installment In This Very long-running
story and we've had an uptick in the
number of people crossing the channel
again in the last week uh they've sort
of taken the opportunity whilst the
weather got a little bit milder a little
bit calmer to Chance The Voyage uh and
you know again we're faced with well
over a hundred thousand uh people who uh
100 uh sorry um who have their
outstanding cases uh many of whom are
going into these systems into hotels
into sort of a temporary accommodation
run by Third parties not run by the
government and it's quite clear I think
in a lot of circumstances that the
facilities are not right that the people
who are running these establishments are
not necessarily well trained and I tell
you what especially given that you know
this is being facilitated
um you know refugees voyages to this
country are being facilitated by
criminal gangs who will look to exploit
people when they're in France they look
to exploit them further along the
chamber we shouldn't then be surprised
when people end up being exploited in
this country as well where those gangs
are operating now allegations of racism
and bullying towards children which is
what this Observer story
um talks about is of course uh it's a
horrible thing actually to think about
that people might come all the way to
this country and face that especially if
they are vulnerable if they are
unaccompanied of their children but
again if it the end result is once again
that people are ending up in the hands
of criminal organizations of people who
wish harm on children and younger people
and this is something that you know it's
not going to be broken this this
ecosystem is not going to be broken
without a lot more resources going into
it and frankly without safer passages
for people to stay not just in the UK
but earlier on in their Journeys you
know the first safe country there need
to be places where people can go to
apply for Asylum and refuge in those
countries before they make the perilous
Journey because it just seems to me that
at every stage people are being shunted
from Pillar To Post and they're not
really safe even when they reach those
safe countries yeah and we can tell you
what the home office have to say about
that we've not received any complaints
in relation to these claims the
well-being of children in our care is an
absolute priority robust safeguards are
in place to ensure they are safe and
supported as we see gauge of placements
with a local Authority when issues do
arise we take complaints extremely
seriously and they are acted upon
quickly a home office spokesperson
responding to that article on the front
of the Observer thank you both for the
moment coming up after the break more of
our press preview including this in the
express us at Kate's mission to give
children a better start to tell you
about that and more in a couple of
minutes no Channel hopping
[Music]
hello again welcome back to part two of
The Press preview uh political
commentator Bandit Spence and Janice and
author Rachel shabby still here Rachel
let's turn our attention to the front of
the Sunday Telegraph the Scottish
government urge to block the transfer of
a violent transgender prisoner from a
Men's prison to a women's jail
um this sort of transgender Rao
continues
yeah so this is the second time in a
week that an issue like this has arisen
um in Scotland Paul first Minister
Nicholas sturgeon as as I understand it
though and I'm not sure I think the
decision is is ultimately with with the
prison estate and that that is made
independently
of government but I I'm not sure I would
need to check that to be honest but yes
it is it does it does raise questions
um of what should be done with these
offenders this piece is reporting that
um
what they describe as a biologically
male prisoner was approved to move to
women's prison but that this offender
was also
um causing problems in the male prison
um attacked female staff while being
held in that prison so that there's
obviously problems to begin with with
violent offenders and what to do with
them and obviously this issue of
um gender has thrown more confusion into
the debate
yeah it really has Benedict hasn't it
and it is an issue that continues to
provoke as Rachel says much debate often
bitter at times
um personally I'm staggered that we
actually have these conversations that
uh people who have been convicted
um not just of any old crime but
specifically of violence and sex
offenses uh people who have been uh
convicted in a court of uh using
violence against women of manipulating
women or you know of of being deceitful
dishonest
um are being considered actually to be
are being taken out their word uh that
they not only are transfer
um uh transitioning to being women you
know just just after they because after
they end up in prison or after they are
convicted uh and also that they won't be
a threat in women's prisons and I think
that this is you know everybody wants to
go through life thinking the best of
people but actually I think if you've
been convicted of certain crimes you
have to take a lot of things with the
people say in relation to things like
this with a pinch of salt and I'm sure
that there are some people who will say
that that is very intolerant and very
harsh but ultimately prisons are
segregated for a reason you know you
have to put the the safety of certain
inmates at the Forefront and if it is a
you know somebody who was born a man and
is a sex offender it doesn't matter
actually whether or not they have
decided to transition to become a Woman
They Are by definition a threat if they
then go into a woman's prison
bullying goes on in male prisons as well
but that is the very basic line that we
have to draw yeah interestingly I
noticed the herald on Sunday
um the Scottish paper on their front
page saying activists are calling for
trans-only prisons for sexual and
violent prisoners is is that an idea
Benedict
I mean if there are sufficient numbers
then it is something that we will have
to consider because actually if there is
a third category
um then ultimately that is what it comes
down to that I will be very honest here
of course people who decide to
transition from male to female who are
in male prisons will also face
um you know significant danger
um yeah that is I'm afraid the the
situation of being in a prison if you
break the law especially if you are a
violent sex offender you are more likely
to be targeted in Brisbane it might
sound very hard we can't just say that
all women must put up with male sex
offenders being put in with them Rachel
just come come back quickly
no woman
um including trans women
should be exposed to violent
sex offenders I think we can all agree
on that
um and yes there we do need to find a
solution but we need to find a solution
that does not
um
Target and demonize an already targeted
and demonized community of trans people
in the UK yeah and you're right by the
way Rachel the Scottish government
spokesperson has said the placement of
prisoners is an operational matter for
the Scottish prison service
um let's just finish with a story well
in fact her photos on the front of most
of the papers of AD of Kate talking
about giving children a better start a
big write-up in the express Rachel
yes not a week goes by without a royal
story for non-royalists like me to cover
does it
sort of a better start I mean there's
not much to object to here she's
launching a major campaign uh to
highlight the critical importance of the
first five years of kids lives they are
formative years
um as we know uh the Princess of Wales
says we need to
um as a society be focused more on that
um than perhaps we do at the moment
where perhaps there's more focus on
later years of childhood uh this article
does point out so it's just not just me
making a political dig although I am
also making a political dig that you
know this is why uh labor introduced
short Start programs when it was in
government and this government scrapped
them all so here we are all right
um thank you both uh very much for that
plenty more to discuss in half an hour
look forward to seeing you uh then right
now let's take a quick look at the
weather